oh my goodness Rhys he's from the MIT
digital coin initiative and he's going
to talk about blockchain ethics today so
let's do the whole day one this is your
thing thank you okay here you go
yep I will not look at this yeah I will
not I am an ethical human being and I
have given you your thing back and let
me start my timer as well yeah indeed
thank you for coming can you hear me
okay see during this last portion so as
a bee-sh it said my name is Rhys and I'm
here from the MIT Media labs digital
currency initiative and I'm here to chat
about blockchain ethics so before I do
that I kind of want to give a little bit
of the motivation here who's read the
moral character of cryptographic work
it's by Phillip Braga way a
cryptographer and i just want to kind of
read it straight up because it kind of
gives the instinct here
he says cryptography rearranges power it
configures who can do what from what
this makes cryptography an inherently
political tool and it confers on the
field and intrinsically moral dimension
the stone revelations from motivate a
reassessment of the political and moral
positioning of cryptography they lead
one to ask if our inability to
ineffectively address mass surveillance
constitutes a failure of our field I
believe that it does I call for a
community-wide effort to develop more
effective means to resist mass
surveillance I plead for a reinvention
of our disciplinary culture to attend
not only to puzzles in math but also the
societal implications of our work it's
very powerful to me and that's I think
some of what I'm bringing here is this
idea that researchers and what Philip is
saying is researchers should also in
addition to think about puzzles mass
alphas also think about societal
implications
yeah the nuclear bomber yeah exactly
yeah you know you could your moral
opinions matter very little technology
can be harnessed by anyone who knows of
it so even if you're morally completely
opposed to it I mean it's all nice and
fair but it's like that the end of
politicians or the you know this yeah so
if I understand your question correctly
its hey there's some kind of new
scientific thing that might be powerful
and then your even if you don't think
that it's a good thing it's not your
opinions that matter it's like how the
world uses it in what the politician is
do with it and all of that it's that
kind of what you're saying they will
carry weight only if you go into them
and say Congress or you know become
whatever it is yeah and I I think I
directionally agree with what you're
saying which is that there is scientists
don't have the if they can't just say oh
I've learned how to make a nuclear bomb
therefore I can choose I have the full
power in this scenario that's definitely
not true however people do have the
ability to a you can reevaluate as
you're building things how you should
build them what you should bill with
them and you can re-evaluate as you're
building things you can kind of affect
the macro system by either speaking in
Congress or changing the norms or things
like that around the technology you
build so it's not a purely just a
one-to-one if you think it's bad then
don't create it but rather think about
the implications and then address the
complex system around that like you know
as a man
I'm putting now my mathematicians have
you know I have my moral fuss but what
I'm supposed to stop pursuing a certain
line of mathematics because I agree or
my like no it's like let me give you an
example maybe which is might be exactly
the you know Phil's point that what that
you like restrain your you read I rest
here he's making it even stronger point
yeah you might be working on problem a
the PCPs but actually the field that
you're in I mean maybe not you
necessarily but a cryptographer might be
working on attribute based encryption
for C CNF blah blah blah and the fact is
you know you've done nothing to address
mass surveillance and so the field has
failed and in fact you might have failed
as well for not addressing the major
problems I'm not a recently do boy but
you like this struggling like math
problems that you think will help yes
yes so I think the visitor what were you
gonna say we're gonna add to that I if I
understand I want to support it the fact
that you know how to do something it
means that you've devoted your life to
how to do this sinc the implication how
to use it and how we affect a society
and whatever you will be the most wrong
person to make decisions of how it
should be used or not used and it's a
mistake to to think you know you know
especially some if you are in if you're
an engineer I like you you can be you
know you're great you could be a
president you can know it's you know
it's almost the opposite yes so if I
understand you correctly what you're
saying is the people who are deep deep
deep down on the research they're the
people who are the least qualified to
actually make the to be presidents and
actually make the societal implications
of those things I think that both true
and not true or it's like having the
domain deep domain expertise makes you
too close to it but also and so that you
can't do like the presidential political
things and I think that knowing deeply
how the technology works might help you
understand some the societal
implications let me make one other meta
point all this I think we should go to
the next slide which is a it's nice to
go after Nils because
with something like libro it's like any
word that he speaks everybody's like you
know and for me that's it's a little bit
easier but it's also harder than that
I'm saying to all of you hey what's your
do you need to be more at the core you
mean need to be more and more or
whatever so I think that that is just a
meta point that will hold throughout
this talk so in any case Philip thinks
this so today we're gonna chat a little
bit about why I think blockchain ethics
is an important in neglected field we're
gonna chat about these three frameworks
to understand blockchain ethics which
are tech ethics financial ethics and
institutional ethics and then we will
conclude with some open questions for
where blockchain ethics is different
than other fields of tech ethics and so
I do want to note that I'm not going to
be making there's gonna be kind of like
a very high-level inch Y or inch deep
mile wide talk not making specific
claims that like X kind of privacy is
good or bad or anything like that so and
there's one where you wanted to point on
that which is what I will be giving you
are these lenses to start to understand
the societal implications not making any
specific claims so the example here is
there's this great parable maybe not as
good as the parable that Eli said
yesterday but a good parable which is
about if you are touching an elephant
depending on where you touch it it looks
like something different and this is
true for the elephant we're at the front
you're like oh it's a speaker at the
back you're like oh it's a rope but I
think this is especially true for
something like bhakti and cryptocurrency
it's a very complex technology and
depending on how you view it and
especially thinking about the long-term
societal implications that can be a very
complex thing and so viewing it from the
multiple different lenses is very
helpful so think of this as kind of like
moving through the idea maze of of this
kind of Bakhtin ethics one note one note
and then a disclosure before I begin is
so yeah as I said my name is Rhys I work
for the MIT digital currency initiative
as the head of community and long-term
societal impact I'm teaching a class
this semester on blockchain ethics with
Nahanni Rula and I've done stuff with
this before like I led the systems in
society track at DEFCON 4
and I also weirdly I self taxed 10% of
my income and you can see I'm open and
transparent with all of my money so this
is my wealth
Agro account this is my ether wallet
this is my Bitcoin wallet so I'm kind of
a very pro transparency in a lot of
strange ways one disclaimer is that I'm
not an academic I do not have a PhD
unlike almost who doesn't who else
doesn't have a PhD yeah
I'm not I was a computer science major
but I'm not a computer scientist an
economic economist or a lawyer I'm just
a dude
okay so dudes are people men women
people everybody everybody comes yes you
do do that see exactly everybody is
welcome
what about the self tax one it means
that yeah great perfect thank you
I recommend it so step one blockchain
ethics is important in the collected
field so I guess it's just a question to
the audience based with a thumb this
being super thumbs up like it will have
a large impact on society something like
the internet this thumbs down being like
and I don't really think Box chain will
have really any impact on society and
thinking of block Gina's both
permissionless blockchain networks like
Bitcoin aetherium also things like
corporate cryptocurrencies and things
like Libre
maybe permission validator networks like
you know permissioned like hyper ledger
and those kind of supply chain things
and or CB DC central bank digital
currencies how large of an impact 1 2 3
how big do we think it's going to be
yeah okay so I agree you say blockchain
blockchain is a technology the way I
look at it then the cryptocurrency is
just piggybacking on some technology
it's the hope I mean it was created for
this but it's it's now an animal for
itself and the blockchain is a
blockchain for other users we
be huge but the coupons sounds like
you're halfway sounds like you're
halfway I would say that the I agree I
mean this is a question of scoping
question for how big it will be but in
general people had like here I would say
pretty large and if you think
something's gonna have a large impact we
should probably be aware of it so
obviously none of us know how big of an
impact it's gonna be but it's think it's
gonna be impactful there have some
conceptual instincts here around
something like the internet how you've
had a lot of work on these underlying
protocols and eventually those manifests
in society in a big way and we're doing
that with like if you think about the
rest of the world everybody outside
versus all of us in here developing
these underlying protocols eventually
they may have a big impact and also when
you change these like core primitives of
society like what the Internet it was
something like information those can
have these long term emergent effects
and so with blockchain we're doing this
with not information but kind of value
and trust and so if you change this core
primitive value then they have some big
impacts you can also see some leading
indicators or proto examples here if you
put the anonymous white paper aka the
Bitcoin white paper on the internet and
then ten years later it's using one 500
of the world electricity you know that's
kind of strange
or as Nilsa it was here Facebook a big
company they announced a blockchain
project you know the CEO spends the
seven hours in front of Congress talking
about it that's another leading
indicator yeah weird metrics like we
might do this thing we kind of have a
white paper boom you know exactly you
must be on the plane also for all of you
researcher types the amount of research
that's been that's happening either on
the privacy side with snarks and Starks
and sharks and halo and Sonic and Aurora
and all the new BFT stuff with hot stuff
and tenormin like there's a lot of new
research happening here with a lot of
new money filling into space so probably
gonna be impactful we'll see in my just
instinct tears if
technology has even 10% of the
Internet's impact we should proactively
take great care in developing it that's
like the high level the intuition so if
we think it will have an impact on
society what should we do create this
few little blockchain ethics and what
that is is it's like a field in the
community of people focused around
answering this question how can we
positively shape the development of
blockchain technology so it's just like
a group of people who are thinking about
this it's similar to these other fields
of tech X as we are chatting about
before when you had something like
nuclear technology you have nuclear
security with a IBM AIX with biotech we
have biotech ethics and so it's
blockchain we kind of would expect
something like blockchain ethics I also
like to think about it as different than
theirs mathematicians are quantum either
qualified is just dudes to have an
opinion it's not like you know yeah I
agree I think that's back to his point
around in this balance between using
domain experts on the ethical societal
implications side and using the domain
experts of the technology and somehow
collaborating between those two for
understanding how to positively shape it
so when you think about this this like
feel block teen ethics it's not really
the state the state does regulation
there's like the SEC in the you know
CFTC and things like that there are
companies on the other side that you
know are optimized generally for profit
and then in the middle there's a sync
old civil society this third space with
academia and nonprofits and community
organizations and unions and that's kind
of where blockchain ethics fits is it in
this like weird third space here and so
the blockchain ethics ecosystem is not
really exactly is not really well formed
yet it were just at the beginning here
you have these three things at the top
and no offense to Peter but these
essentially law I mean they're very good
educational but they're lobbying
organizations and then you have folks
like open money initiative and some
other things like this that are trying
to help how like using blockchain in
developed countries and you have like
some of these academic research labs
that are a little bit more ethically
facing but if you compare this to
something like the AI ethics ecosystem
it's crazy you have these things that
are tens of millions hundreds of
millions of dollars of funding with
dozens of centers around the world and
it's a much more mature ecosystem and so
yeah we what I would expect is like you
know fifteen years ago there was that's
a tumbleweed there was like nothing
really in the AI ethics world uh-huh and
now it's like there's a whole robust
ecosystem and similarly with blockchain
ethics we may expect to see something
similar a lot of nonprofits are funded
principally through Bitcoin they got
huge donations because a lot of picked
by maximalists in the early days we're
super scared of a can you give examples
yeah I think in so like open a I had a
big thing from Peter to you I know that
the pineapple fund which gave fifty five
million dollars of bitcoins of stuff
maybe like a quarter of it went to Miri
and some of these other AI ethics
Research Center's that's a good question
so I think my personal instinct is so
we're just at the beginning this one
started within the last year this one
started I guess two or three years ago
exactly and some of them have yeah and
some of them yeah some of them have
super long term like these ones are more
like the effective altruists long term
AGI facing ones while some of these
other ones like data and society and
fats are more about like AI fairness and
racial discrimination these things so I
think that I would say they have been
successful thus far at least elevating
the conversation and then they have a
bunch of
different mechanisms for implementing
change some of which are things like
supporting protesters at companies like
Facebook or Google or whatever to push
against their decisions and things like
that so I don't I wouldn't be able to
tell if they've had hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of impact but they I
think they have had some impact
sorry full-time employees sorry that
this is just I didn't I couldn't get
their amount of funding so this was just
the amount of people it's a good
question I think that I personally don't
know very much about that I know that
the Stanford human high center human
centered artificial intelligence I know
they're funded a lot by bides by either
Baidu or $0.10 but I don't know what the
ethics ecosystem looks like in in China
could it be that the reason why this
field is so well-funded
is because it poses so much greater risk
than blockchain yeah great question
hay is actually having impact on the
world while blockchain for all intensive
purposes has not really and so and
there's another argument which is what
are the long-term implications if you
think about making exporting or
delegating decisions to computers in a
lot of different ways then yeah you
could argue that that will have longer
you know bigger impact on society than
something like blockchain so maybe it's
the case that the you know blockchain
ethics ecosystem should only have ten
people here instead of six or whatever
but the fact that close to zero I think
is my main point inherently socialist
while blockchain is apparently
libertarian so maybe he funds a lot of
pay is nice
nice thank you Peter
catastrophes are better televised you
know terminating our movies and
financial meltdowns or you know make for
poor movies yeah exactly
oh that dude again yeah I think that the
I agree though in general and that's why
when you change these core primitives
like something like the inert like
thinking of changing the core primitive
of information and then seeing something
like Facebook red feed blue feed things
is a hard jump to make and I think that
changing these core parameters of value
there's no clear like Terminator
scenario from that's like oh if we have
this weird like yeah understanding that
I think is hard for people to
conceptualize so in any case I think
that it is the case that blockchain is a
at least moderately important field and
it is definitely neglected at this point
in time any other thoughts okay we're
chatting about these three frameworks um
the nice thing is that so their tech
ethics financial ethics and
institutional ethics the tech ethics is
like thinking of this as technology and
also drawing from the tech ethics field
which already exists financial ethics is
thinking of this thing is like money and
thinking about like the already existing
regulatory bodies there and an
institutional ethics is thinking of
these new blockchain cryptocurrency
networks as new kinds of like like
mythical entities that can coordinate
and motivate humans like things like the
firm or the nation-state and things like
that so yeah these are lenses let's chat
about tech ethics so is that what chains
are a new way to sort of reach consent
massive scales right now it's about mr.
payment at some other time it could be a
you know means for causing major
political disruptions work things that
are clearly yeah I'm moral in more like
you know genocide or whatnot so where
does that kind of ethics fall in and so
tell me how how would the genocide how
would block chain lead to genocide
consensus like you know you put your
whatever he there's like you put the
commitment in a way that can only be
done in one in you know like reach
consensus or we use it as a tool for
reaching consensus on things that are
hard to reach consensus let's say today
through the standard political mechanism
assassination mark so it depends on I
think that in general that would
probably fit within the realm of tech
ethics where it's saying okay we have
this or use the assassination markets
example so there are these prediction
market platforms like gnosis or augur
and what they do is they say hey what
are that you can open a market there in
this permissionless decentralized way
that says hey I'm going to what are the
odds that Donald Trump is alive at the
end of 2020 and then what you do is you
put money on one or the other side of
that and you can imagine you're
essentially putting a market for like oh
should this person die or whatever and
then usually those kinds of markets when
they exist in traditional betting
platforms they get taken down but when
they exist on these permissionless trust
lists decentralized boxing platforms and
it might be a little bit harder to take
them down and so that would be an issue
of I would put that in the tech ethics
bucket because as part of these new
kinds that the technical affordances of
permissionless of a permissionless
protocol or what enables that that
outcome I'll say a little bit more on
that in a second but that's right in
general put that blockchain apocalypse
it seems like if you generalize what
what it would be is
the removal of real-world authority and
the replacement of it with some kind of
algorithmic Authority which may have
unintended consequence so if you
suddenly spool forward in the same way
if you spool for an AI you come up with
Terminator or whatever you could spool
forward blockchain and come up with a
world where all of the worlds all the
authorities have been neutered and
there's essentially not not Anarchy but
basically rules which nobody can control
which are which and you could be a
ticket be these murder markets or
there's a million examples
yes I think and maybe that if you state
in that form that might be closer to
institutional ethics institutional
ethics is about things like markets and
firms and how and if you think about
something like Facebook and the rise of
Facebook in society and how that changed
our sense making it information
landscapes and how he had kind of a
revolution from our existing landscape
to our current landscape that that
revolution has had lots of kind of
destabilizing effects on society
if you imagine a similar revolution with
respects like banking or how money flows
then that may have similarly
destabilizing effects on society away
from trusted centralized institutions
towards bottom-up emergent behavior
stuff yeah somebody case what tech
ethics is not this is kind of confusing
for people it's kind of annoying phrase
that nobody in the tech ethics world
likes it is it's not philosophizing
about abstract notions of what to do or
thinking about utilitarianism or any of
these you don't like think about
theories or things like that really what
you do is you just say okay what is the
system what is this complex system you
have like laws and policy you have like
the economics in the market you have the
technology in the code you have like
your culture and your norms have those
things like co-evolved with each other
affect each other
ah [ __ ] like okay now we can determine
some of the impacts oh this might be
positive this might be negative and then
you try to intervene in that system
that's really what people talk about
when they're talking about tech ethics
so it's less of just like a
philosophical ethical notion thing so
yeah you look at the affordances you
look at the impact so then you try to
intervene if I look at blockchains
affordances people could disagree on
which ones to highlight here but I think
of it as
you have this immutable distributed
database where you have it's hard to go
backwards in time and change I'm mostly
thinking about permissionless blockchain
that works here it's hard to go back in
time and change things and you also
instead of having a centralized lecture
you have this distributed ledger you
also have the cryptography piece that
has public and private key pairs
it's that only I with my private key can
spend my money and the government can't
take that and then you also have this
pseudonymous on the database you have
these essentially public keys that are
on the database that are not anonymous
but are pseudonymous and they also have
protocols and decentralization for
unstoppable code this one's a little bit
more confusing you can imagine this as
like these these are some of the initial
layers of the internet and those are
these protocols like TCP IP and you can
imagine this new layer these kind of
blockchain protocols as these protocols
for value instead of protocols for
information and once you have these
protocols and a protocol kind of by
nature is this is like a trustless
permissionless system where you can just
like access it what that allows for is
decentralization of the system so this
is a list of all the like the Bitcoin
nodes in the world or a map of all of
them and the reason why you can get
something like that is because anybody
can tap into the network and can just
conform to the protocol and so what that
that protocol and that trustless system
that permissionless leads to this
decentralization and what that
decentralization leads to is like
unstoppable code or censorship resistant
money and what that means is that you
have if you have something like Bitcoin
you want send Bitcoin somewhere else in
the world it's very hard for the
government to say like stop doing that
because and they say oh should I hit the
exchange really hit the miners should I
hit the human that kind of thing so
that's kind of what this third one means
is that you have these protocols and
this decentralization that lead to this
unstoppable code and so for each of
these things you can think about the
impact of the affordances and almost all
of these almost all when you're thinking
from a tech ethics perspective you have
all these kind of tensions that exist
where you have some kind of affordance
and it has both good things and bad
things
and so that immutable distributed
database one thing that people talk
about from the negative side a lot in
their research papers about this they're
like
GDP ours right to be forgotten it's like
how we're gonna do that it's like they
need one on a database
there's the cryptography piece it
obviously provides you some privacy but
obviously on the negative side we've
seen the like link ability of this
that's like you know pseudonymous is not
anonymous also what we are talking about
with or my question to Mill's earlier
was that these permissionless protocols
we've got something like the early
internet so beautiful like let's a
thousand flowers bloom a bunch of
different things can exist but then if
you decrease the friction then that can
lead to resent realization and so we've
seen that with aggregation theory or
early kind of or worth like the internet
web 2.0 platforms and we also see that
to some extent with blockchain mining
and things like that
and as we've been chatting about a while
today it's like this decentralization
piece is both good because then it
allows the government can't punish you
it allows you to yeah exactly that's
good that's great
yeah when it could be good could be bad
yeah I agree there's yes if I think an
example here might be something like the
capital controls in different countries
and something like Venezuela how hard or
easy it is to get US dollars versus how
hard or easy it is to access Bitcoin and
that the something like desensitization
might make it even though the government
can make things illegal it might make it
harder for them to say like to punish
like the network I guess two things here
that people would disagree on whether
they're happy face front
exactly and that's kind of the point I'm
trying to make here which is that almost
all these affordances can be viewed as a
tension between the positive and
negative aspects so that's how tech FX
folks see the world in general and I
would say I think that Primavera noted
this yesterday's when you think about
intervening in these systems the way you
should think about it is by using this
guy Lawrence Lessig in his
dot which is this idea that if you are
trying to change something in a system
you can either change it with laws so
you can say like oh we want you know we
don't want this thing to happen like
let's make a law to make it illegal or
you can change with market so you can
like incentivize people or
disincentivize people to do it you can
change it with norms so you can like
praise people or shame people for doing
the thing or you can change it with code
where you change the underlying code and
so when you think about something that
is good or bad in a system and you're
saying oh I want to change this thing I
think a lot of us will naturally go to
law and be like oh let's change it with
law or maybe a lot of us here might say
oh let's actually just change the code
there but I think thinking about the
whole set of the answers here is very
powerful so that is essentially what the
tech ethics perspective looks like for
blockchain ethics
what is very unique for blockchain and
many of those visitors like for
databases 12 systems onion system what
kind of other systems attempt they say
what is the very unique for blockchain
yeah great question so his question is
hey all of these things look like things
that already exist just databases exist
with you know things like Facebook and
things like that
cryptography has existed for a long time
and like into end encryption doing that
without sending money along and then
these protocols and decentralization
like this is the Internet in many ways
there are these new protocols yes so I
think that the I would say in general I
like to look at the existing examples to
understand how blockchain works so
really just using the the full set of of
essentially actively leaning into your
question saying they are the same we
should think of them as similar things
and we should use similar ideas and I
think when you get to this next section
the thing that we'll see is different is
that you're sending money along and that
you're it's a value based technology
rather than information based technology
technical ethics what should you do good
question so the question is how for the
builders or the researcher of the world
how would they actually embody or
manifest some of these ideas and
actually implement some of these ideas
of tech ethics
it is hard there's um this thing if you
go to ethical OS com
that's just a great list of resources to
say like you essentially check all these
different risk zones and then based off
of those risk zones then you say oh is
this gonna be good or bad and then from
that you you like change how you might
build the technology what I've seen
general is I think being aware thinking
that technology is not being aware of
this in general is good thinking that
technology is not necessarily neutral
but it could be predisposed to be good
or bad it's kind of projecting into the
future when you build something Oh
what could be the positive impacts of
the technology you know looking at kind
of this I don't know any technology or
science that cannot be used for good
things and for bad things it's like the
guns kill people or do people kill
people thing and it's like and I think
that the thing that argue for is that
yes both guns and hammers do kill people
but guns might kill people more easily
than hammers and similarly with some of
these technologies that we build if you
build a technology that has certain
incentives built into it or certain
technical affordances then it might be
more easily used to do bad things
and so you can if you think about that
you think about you project in the
future those positive and negative
implications and then all you do
essentially or what I'd recommend is you
just think about this dot and you say
it's like let's say you're building your
your Stark X and you're worried that
people are going to that a bunch of
child pornography folks are going to use
it to bats there sees it as this
exchange such that I guess I don't know
if the zero knowledge exists but the
they might use in this privacy way and
what I would ask you is I would you know
I would recommend you think about how
you're sharing the technology initially
what kinds of groups you share it with
maybe as you start to build your
community around it starting to shape
the norms and like trying to shame
people in the community around if they
like using it for child porn or ever
maybe talk with lawyers about how to
think about so so yeah it's being
self-aware thinking about the future and
then starting to use this maybe about
this you are a co-creator of Z cash so
this is you you are one of the people
who deployed this technology to some
degree and you did actually establish
norms and a law and code for example
establishing the Keshe foundation is an
act of a it could be viewed under the
ethical framework I think yeah limiting
the founders reward there have been many
actions the company did that could be
considered under the viewing key
I would classify a lot of them less
under the technology or science and more
under the of course when you're let's
say meeting some effort that involves
humans you can then of course ethics is
very well most of these things are right
law and norms and markets are not -
what's interesting about what Ellie just
says in in law at least this is sort of
a metaphor we have a division between in
the u.s. speech and conduct and both
might be expressive and bringing to the
world things in the US we say it's
purely speech it's necessary to allow
that it's in necessary to not think
twice about that we don't even want to
chill speech let alone make it illegal
but if it's expressive conduct where
you've taken speech and you've done
something with it like you're burning a
flag now you're not just voicing your
opposition to the Vietnam War then it's
okay maybe to intervene then it's okay
maybe to force some sort of greater
sense of social responsibility on the
person because they're engaged in
activity that can have real consequences
at the extreme end of expressive conduct
you could imagine flying the building
into a plane it's very expressive
conduct but of course it would never
have any protection under the
Constitution as speech because at this
point would got massive societal
implications so maybe writing the the
white paper or co-authoring a white
paper describing how to implement zero
knowledge Bruce and blockchain is
something that we don't think you should
have too much of a moral obligation to
question because then we'd be stifling
the free flow of important scientific
ideas but then actually implementing the
white paper into a working blockchain
telling people they should use it to
move their money around telling people
that maybe should have feature a or B in
order to prevent it's used by terrorists
or allow law enforcement certain access
to certain things that's a different
story
so it seems like an interesting parallel
so it's hard though obviously it's hard
so let's chat about the financial ethics
side for a second
the nice thing also by the way is that
aviv already both aviv and nils already
talked about two of the big buckets here
so we can kind of zoom through there's
been financial ethics in history right
now people don't really care about this
or don't care about the
as much because cryptocurrencies only
200 billion dollar market cap which is
40 X less than gold which is about eight
trillion dollar market cap and which is
a lot less than stocks and money and
derivatives which are like seventy to
seventy a seven hundred trillion so
we're still in the very beginning stages
here of the financial ethics piece if I
think about financial ethics there are
two kind of big buckets there's the
public policy goals and then there's
thinking about money and incentives as
kind of a primitive and what that allows
so on the public policy goal side
they're all about managing risks and
information asymmetries and as we chat
about the guarding against illicit
activities we were chatting about today
with you know kyc and AML and those
kinds of things from this perspective
you think of it as money and you have
these regulatory bodies like you know
early this morning we were talking about
the fa TF a lot you can also think of it
as another big policy goal is investor
in consumer protection and so from that
perspective you think of cryptocurrency
as missus cryptocurrency sorry for the
cryptographers cryptocurrency as
security a commodity or derivative and
that's folks like SEC and the CFTC in
the US you think about this and then the
final one and actually an example a
funny example that is from a securities
perspective there's recently coinbase
and others made this crypto rating
council with these eight folks and what
they did is they looked at securities
law and kind of gave these ratings about
it that said like okay we're going to
from 1 through 5 I'm not sure if you can
see us but we're gonna rate things as
like not totally not a security or
totally a security with like Bitcoin
being a 1 and then aetherium being a 2
and like different things having like
random different amounts here so we're
starting to see people chat about this
securities thing and then legal
compliance strategy not necessarily like
an ethics strategy and I think it's
actually dangerous that it can be
confused as the other oh this is a 4 on
the claim base ranking it's a good thing
no no they were just saying whether
we're likely as exchanges to get in
trouble trading it with the SE
whether it's a good thing it's kind of
strange yeah I think so I'd say that the
ethical piece from a pure ethics
perspective the way I think about this
is that we had we have these ethical
ideas in society ethical and moral kind
of concepts of what is good more as bad
those eventually get implemented and
codified into policy goals and things
like that and that these policy goals of
investor and consumer protection it's
like you know selling people's snake
oils not great and then that turned into
stuff like the SEC and the CFTC into
these big regulatory bodies and then we
see instead of this like top-down SEC or
CFTC saying X Y Z is a security or not a
security we see these self-regulatory
organizations like this where they're
saying like oh these things are there
yeah they're trying to it's a protection
strategy for their own business and I
think that the question here is whether
their intention is to avoid regulation
from above or whether their intention is
to be good ethical actors and to make
sure that people on their platforms
don't buy scam be kinds and things like
that right but they trade securities so
they have over tokens that's that I mean
because token securities are like a
token of equity ownership sure sure but
they trade them things that are always
regulated by the SEC whereas this is a
rubric to figure out what you can trade
that would not be regulated but yes but
it's a first step I mean Nasdaq started
this way and the FASB started this way
as well we sort of to avoid to avoid
more onerous regulation you
self-regulate so you can say we're doing
something and they're treasurer best
yeah and I think Peter would know a lot
more about whether this is like a good
or a bad thing or honor but this is just
a this is some of the initial work
that's being done this base in kind of
this weird new world where it's like oh
it's not necessarily a security or not a
security it's like maybe it lists like
one through five it's like this mV
around the final piece by the final
policy goal that we traditionally think
about is macro systemic stability and
this is the thing that Mills was
chatting about where and that Facebook
has gotten a lot of work people are
worried about Facebook and and Libra is
that hey we have this new money and it
could change monetary policy around the
world and could you know remove monetary
policy from the ability of like
developing countries to enact their own
monetary policy and so that regulatory
our bodies are things like the Fed and
central banks around the world things
like that that's one side of this is the
traditional public policy goals the
other side of this is the more general
impact of money and incentives on
society this is kind of a this is a
weird one but this is just thinking like
if you have money as a thing or if you
have incentives as a thing what does
that lead to and again all these have
positive and negative impacts I think we
don't need to watch this clip but on the
positive side with something like money
it's like greed is good
greed incentivizes us to do good things
and on the negative side like people
will do anything for money
and we've seen this with the
cryptocurrency world in a pretty extreme
way the other side of this is that you
can start to use on the positive side
like you can use mechanism design and
game theory for good in these beautiful
ways but you can also use like game
theory as a dark art do people know who
knows FOMO 3d people this was a cool
thing where they essentially was an
aetherium smart contract where you could
there's one ethan the smart contract and
you could access that smart Khan you
could say oh I want to get that one II
by paying point one east if I held it
only if I held it for 24 hours though so
I pay my point one eath gets added to
the bucket now there's one point one
east I'm trying to horn for 24 24 hours
but then damn somebody else comes in it
says oh I love asleep eh my point one
eath to get this one point 1/8 here so
they do it and then everybody just keeps
on doing it keeps on doing it until the
the bucket of that was just one Heath
had 53,000 eath which is like 12 million
dollars at the time and some people are
calling this game theory as a dark art
because they were making this new system
that said hey we're gonna mess with
people and mess with incentives and then
essentially yeah make this weird new
exit say yeah make this weird new system
so what happened in the end is when it
overflowed oh that would be nice if that
would happen what actually happened is
there were a bunch of bots who were
participating at near the end and it was
essentially only BOTS a human was able
to look at all the different BOTS was
able to say ah how did they all work he
was able to hear she was able to look at
all those BOTS determine how they work
and then mess understand their algorithm
for gas pricing on the etherium Network
trigger them to think that the gas
prices were lower than they actually
were and then he was able to get in on
some blocks the bots were going thinking
that the gas prices were low and we're
sending low gas prices when there was
actually high gas prices and then he won
the exit scam for 12 million bucks yeah
so but yeah you could we can use game
theory in some evil negative ways in
your BOTS how do you write the part that
gives the gas price for something you
want but I think the promo 3d people
also like got a percentage out of the
bucket regardez hopes it's time they got
a percentage yeah they made the thing so
they deserve you know for developing
even we're worried about that people
were worried it was just gonna suck up
all the he join his Ponzi scheme if you
want oh so um I think and by the way we
have about five minutes left so we're
gonna zoom through a bit I think the
main other impact of money thing that I
want to highlight here is just this
ignores externalities peace where you
have money as a thing it optimizes for
certain things like securing the Bitcoin
network but that doesn't take into
account the negative externalities of
energy use and like climate change and
so we have some of those issues as well
so this is to say financial ethics can
be thought of either from the
traditional public policy goals
perspective which EV is a heaven existed
for a long time or the like money and
incentives as a primitive perspective
let's do let's essentially just do
institutional ethics and then we can
wrap up so institutional ethics so
institutional ethics is mostly a made-up
term by me but it's part of this field
of new institutional economics which is
which started with this guy Ronald Coase
in the theory of the firm in 1937 and he
asked the question hey if markets are so
good at allocating resources why do
firms also exist why do we have these
two kinds of like institutions in
society and the answer that he gave was
ah it comes down to these like
transaction costs where if you're in a
firm you have your more efficient
transaction cost you can just like tell
people to do things versus in a market
you have to be like hey here's some
money like so on please do this thing
and so that's why both of them exists he
hypothesized at this time it's kind of
kick-started this field of new
institutional economics and we've seen
it with other things more recently with
stuff like the internet where you have
there's great piece by yokai benkler
called kosis penguin or Linux in the
nature of the firm that was in 2002 and
it's this idea of commons-based peer
perta peer production as a new way of of
coordinating and motivating people and
so yokai asked the question like why
does Linux why do Linux are wicked
tinea exist and again he looked at it
from this new institutional economics
perspective thought about the
transaction cost thought about what they
were incentivized to do and said oh this
is interesting
like Wikipedia and other open-source
projects are new kind of like motivating
coordinating force in society because
they have they incentivize people and
have different transaction cost in
different ways so this field of
institutional economics we can think of
these we can also map this into the
world of like you know blockchain and
crypto currencies where you have a bunch
of these already existing institutions
that we know of in society like firms
and markets and also the nation-states
and religions and then we also have
these new blockchain and cryptocurrency
networks which again motivate and
coordinate people in this interesting
way and so you can start to think of it
from an institutional coevolution
perspective where these institutions are
kind of Co evolving with each other
competing for our time and energy to
participate in them and so yeah a bunch
of them exist and when you're thinking
from this perspective of institutional
economics in general you see you see the
world through like instead of you see
the world through the producers instead
of through the consumers so with
something like Wikipedia versus a firm
versus a market you're asking the
question like where do I as a human like
do I want to participate in the Bitcoin
protocol I want to participate like
Wikipedia as a thing like where do I
want to add my time and energy you also
yeah you see the world is like a bunch
of Ledger's you see the world through
transaction costs and through trust in
these big ways you think about how
information and capital flow in these
systems and you think about as being as
primavera was trying them yesterday like
two days ago the governance of these
systems how do these new institutions
make decisions and a crucial one here
especially with Bachchan crypto is the
stories behind these institutions so
something like these new blockchain
networks
something like Bitcoin is saying hey you
know given the like let's exit the
nation-state looks like we run away from
this existing system and build this new
world over here and then that then
incentivizes people like oh that's a
cool new reality that I won't like take
part in
so yeah what I would say is yeah you can
ask these questions for how blockchain
Networks compete and the thing that Eli
was just asking Nell's about is this
which is this idea that you have these
new kinds of you have these web 2.0
platforms which had these api's had
people build on those api's but then
those AP eyes were closed to the world
and then those people like Farmville or
people building off a twitter we're sad
and so what you have in the future what
we have now is something like the
etherium blockchain it's very hard to
close those ap eyes on the etherion
blockchain because you can just like you
build the smart contract it's there it's
gonna run and so that's what they call
developer integrity so these new web 3.0
or these new block G network platforms
have high developer integrity and they
have right now their developer
experience is really bad but the hope is
or the idea is that over time the
developer experience will get better and
better and it's built on this underlying
strong developer integrity thing where
you can't turn off the api's while
something like you know Facebook or
Google or whatever they have the
centralized platform and they won't ever
be able to get up to this high developer
integrity level so this is kind of the
things that something like these
blockchain networks are competing with
these web 2.0 networks on is something
like developer integrity yeah I really
see one of the thing yeah another thing
that you can imagine them competing on
is the story behind the thing so this is
I know a lot of my friends were into the
blockchain cryptocurrency world who are
you know if your developer these days
you have enough money and you're looking
to like find meaning in the world at
this point and so you're essentially
looking for something like self
actualization you're looking for meaning
and so this world of cryptocurrency in
democratized incentives and being able
to participate in this new building of
the new Internet
that's what incentivizes people to go to
that world and they're like oh there's
gonna be super exciting and like
intellectually curious I'm gonna get
meaning over there and again over time
it kind of sucks too
in that world but that it'll get better
versus something like an offense but
like Gaffa in surveillance capitalism or
whatever is like a world it's like oh do
I want to like go somewhere like make it
so that people click more ads it's like
that is a I think a lot of people are
like oh I'll go and do this world
instead of this world so again this is
institutional competition between
blockchain networks and these like web
2.0 platforms yeah so what tel is saying
is that right now in 2019 this is up
here because this new exciting thing
that doesn't have any business model
problems and whatever but then over time
it's like oh [ __ ] this thing's actually
getting built they've all of societies
into it it's like a bad business model
of variety ways and then the people that
the self-actualization for developers
will be like I don't want to join that
thing cuz it's not providing me with
meaning is that your point and I agree I
think that that's mostly true but right
now at least this is a competitive
advantage I would say for these crypto
networks so I think that let me say one
final piece and then we'll wrap up which
is the my main thing when thinking from
a institutional ethics perspective is
what we were chatting about earlier
which is evolution not revolution there
are these concepts of creative
destruction externalities which is where
you when you build a new thing you kind
of destroy the old thing like when you
built a new you know when ice when
people started people used to ship ice
all around the world and then we had
refrigerators and all the people that
used to work in the ice industry no
longer could work in ice industry and so
that was both sad but long-term good and
so similarly we've seen this with our
information ecosystem and we should be
worried about it as well for our for the
Bitcoin and blockchain ecosystem but
something like this being the second
highest post on the our stash bit
connect subreddit which is a subreddit
of for this like bad scamming
cryptocurrency
which is like a suicide hotline for when
people when it went really far down so
we just need to be aware of as we're
building these new systems to not just
like build them willy-nilly
so with that there were three helpful
ways to view blockchain ethics and I
guess I would recommend all of you and
you can go to
Gina ethics co2 check out this stuff and
you can view a whole syllabus and that's
that thank you any questions